all right so we are going to be trying
to attempt to do the uh jet passive
skill jump the catch is danny and i
don't know what we're doing one and two
only have 20 seconds to do it are you
ready uh no but let's do it one two
three
go
oh i didn't let go let go no the attempt
was there a for effort let go what
out of town
one more
three two
one go watch us watch it swatches okay
nope not that don't watch that
oh that was close oh close you got one
more one more one more
four
three
oh i felt i felt it in my bones so am i
the better jet mane out of the two of us
danny and you do this
that was really cute danny wait come
here
that can only danny one jet